more schools around the valley also  paying their respects joseph m neal's  steam academy held a ceremony principal  denise murray has a personal connection  her husband used to work at the world  trade center and knew many of those who  were killed she talked about how the  school explains these attacks to kids  who weren't even born when it happened  you can't sugarcoat this it's a tragic  terrible thing but you must make them  know that they are safe their families  keep them safe and we keep them  safe so important to end with that the  school by the way has been doing the  ceremony for 15 years valley high school  also held a ceremony this morning the  american flag raised by the jrotc in  remembrance of those killed  parents staff and other students  gathered to pay their respects